All
right
from the age of five onwards.
So it was one of the earliest things I
started to read when I started to read.
And,
uh,
it was very much part of my
consciousness in the beginning.
I saw the Bhagavad Gita is a text that
was very classical,
most like the Iliad and the Odyssey,
a mythical saga that showed the eternal
conflict between good and evil.
But much later as I grew up,
I realized that it was much more than
that.
It what it was an examination of
consciousness and the desire of human
beings or the quest that we have as
human beings to understand ourselves.
That it was the map you might say,
for exploring the territory.
And that leads us to find out things
about ourselves.
Who are we?
Where do we come from?
What's the meaning and purpose of our
existence?
Uh,
do we have a soul?
What happens to us after we die?
Does God Exist?
Does God in fact care about us?
How can we get in touch with that source
that we call consciousness is the
consciousness behind our thoughts.
Also the consciousness responsible for
all the intelligent activity of the
universe.
The bhagavad Gita is actually a very
good text for Yoga,
the Yoga of love,
the Yoga of action or Karma,
the yoga of understanding or intellect
and the yoga of reflection and
meditation.
So I think it's a very important a map
for understanding the nature of
consciousness.
The word Yoga is the same as the English
Word York.
Uh,
so in the New Testament when Jesus
Christ says,
my yoke is easy and my burden is light,
my interpretation is that he's referring
to yoga.
It Means Union,
Union of the body,
mind and spirit as one continuum of
consciousness.
I think the Bhagavad Gita is about,
um,
both are the forces of light and the
forces of darkness that exists within
our own self,
within our own soul,
that our deepest nature is one of
ambiguity.
We have evolutionary forces,
their forces of creativity and love and
compassion and understanding.
But we also have darkness inside us.
The diabolical forces of separation,
fear and delusion.
And a,
in most of our lives,
there's a battle going on within
ourselves between the sacred and the
profane,
between the evolutionary impulses and
the destructive tendencies that we have
between creativity on the one hand and
addictive behavior.
On the other hand,
between the divine and the Diabolico
between the light and the shadow between
the sacred and the profane.
So the [inaudible] Gita is a,
an understanding of this battle that we
have in our consciousness that
ultimately is played out in the
battlefield,
as you recall,
our physical bodies in the physical
universe.
So by understanding the dynamics of
these forces within our own
consciousness and by beginning to
harmonize our impulses with the
evolutionary impulse within us,
we heal ourselves.
And in doing so,
we heal not only our physical bodies but
our world because the world that we find
ourselves in is a projection both of our
personal consciousness and our
collective consciousness.
So I think it's very relevant to modern
times when you see things like global
warming and climate chaos and changing
weather patterns and natural disasters
like Hurricane Katrina and extreme
poverty and economic disparities and
social injustice and war.
And terrorism.
These are the projection or the
collective consciousness that's in
disarray of a collective consciousness
where there is a rift in the collective
soul,
a collective consciousness that,
uh,
is evolving.
But,
um,
he was going through a lunch.
Okay.